here's what would happen if birds were  government surveillance drones  the birds aren't real movement began in  1976. it detailed a conspiracy to  eliminate all birds with a deadly virus  according to the movement between 1959  and 2001 the United States government  replaced birds with robotic drones  if it were true the CIA would have 12  million Birds tracking and surveilling  our every movement  with so many drone Birds fluttering  around you could never be sure that your  conversations were private you'd need a  soundproof windowless room in your house  to avoid the prying eyes of these birds  you could be stuck with a tracking  device leaking all your secrets to the  government and never look a bird  directly in their eyes their cameras I  mean their eyes could be scanning your  retinas to steal your information so